a hydraulic arm Kevlar coating and
multiple emergency hatches this is not
your average living structure that's
because it's one of the world's first
tornado proof houses a Hong Kong
architecture firm came up with the idea
to protect people against recurring
natural disasters these futuristic
designs have hydraulic levers that can
lift the structure off the ground or
drop it below the surface to keep it
protected from a violent storm the
spaceship lighthouse has a translucent
outer skin and clear insulation
sandwiched between two layers of Kevlar
that acts as a weather barrier the
square-shaped design has two bedrooms
and one bathroom the roof is a concrete
grid with glass panel inserts that can
handle the force of a falling car the
plan calls for building entire
neighborhoods of tornado-proof homes
when there's violent weather warning
they would all drop underground together
for safety the architects are hoping to
construct a prototype in a region called
Tornado Alley the central and southern
plains of the US are the breeding ground
for most of these violent storms an area
where cold moist and hot dry air all
meet at the same time a farmer in Kansas
who has lived through five serious
tornadoes has offered his land for the
tornado proof house first the designers
have to come up with a $500,000 it will
cost to build it
you